- Well, Michelle, you say
Maximus has had to deal
with a lot of different reactions
as a black male dancer, right?
- Yes, we're a military family
and Maximus physically
lives five different places
and he's also been to five
different dance studios.
And those dancers are white females and,
Maximus is obviously neither of those.
So often when he goes
to a new dance studio,
he'll come home sad because he says
no one's talked to talks to him
and he sits in the corner by himself.
But then, once maximums finally
does some different dance moves
and people see that he's actually
just as passionate
about dance as they are,
then they embrace him,
and then he becomes friends and--
- Look at him!
You get it, Maximus!
- This is our house all day, every day.
- I swear to God, if I could do that,
I'd be doing it right now.
(laughter)
- Hey, if you could do that
that's exactly how they'd
take you to the hospital.
(laughter)
- I'd be like, stuck.
Well, Maximus, you say
you wanna be a role model
to other young dancers, right?
- Definitely, so one
time somebody was like,
"Oh, boys don't dance."
And I was like, "Yes, they do."
And so I think that all boys should dance,
including you, Terry.
(laughter)